i was watching a uh video on numberphile
with matt in it on witness numbers and
testing whether a number might or might
not be a prime right super good video
and at one point in the video
they talk about the sum 23 to the power
of
373 mods
747. that isn't something you can
necessarily do on a pocket calculator so
in the video you know they use wall from
alpha i'm going to cheat and uh ask what
from alpha
yeah
very reasonable i use wall from alpha
all the time but actually there's a
really really nice algorithm under here
that i wanted to talk about today
in a number file video this was about
primarily testing and testing whether a
number might or might not be a prime
in this case actually where you you'll
see this often used is in stuff like rsa
public key cryptography and so
actually the numbers get much much
bigger than this right so you might have
some number to the power of a 2000 bit
number so let's say you know 600 or more
digits
modulo some other 2000 bit number and
the mathematics is so extraordinarily
vast that you can't comprehend how this
could possibly be calculated the fact
that we can reduce this modulo 747 so
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the modulus it means you divide by
747 and then find the remainder so it's
a bit like a clock thing is it's exactly
like a clock yeah you go all the way
round to 12 when you start back at one
two three it's that but obviously your
numbers are bigger there's many more
hours in a day even if you calculate
this modulus this is still a difficult
sum because you have to do 23 times 23
times 23 times 23 373 times
that's that's not very fast right and
it's 373 was a 600 digit number then
even by taking mod
there's no hope of doing this right so
we need some kind of algorithm that
calculates what we call an
exponentiation much much faster and that
is a square and multiply algorithm
really neatly allowed with them i think
fairly intuitive to understand um and
it's used all the time in computer
science whenever whenever you have a sum
like this which is a lot of the time you
can do it really really quickly using
square and multiply now actually as it
happens they picked a quite difficult
sum right there there's reasons for this
and we'll go into them but i'm going to
pick a slightly easier sum perhaps the
first thing to do is to look at
how the square multiplier will work sort
of an overview right and the idea is
basically if we square a number we can
get towards 2 23 to the 33 much more
quickly right so for example suppose you
were calculating 2 to the power of 8.
that is 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 times 2. how many is that
times 2 right now that took me a fair
while to write out but actually you
could save yourself a little bit of time
because you could do
two times two is two to the
two that's two squared right
then two squared
times by 2 squared
is 2 to the 4. it's 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 right
and then if we do square this again we
can go we can jump all the way up to 2
to the 4 2 to the 4 is 2 to the 8. and
so we can actually do it in one two
three operations we can get to two to
the eight instead of this seven or eight
operations if instead of multiplying by
your original value every time you
multiply by one of these much larger
intermediate values you can much more
quickly converge on the solution you
want assuming it's a power of two right
we haven't dealt with a slightly prickly
subject of what happens if this isn't
just a power of two which unfortunately
cryptography is most of the time so in
principle the idea is that we can sort
of jump forward in powers of two
or you know it's by squaring much more
quickly but we need some kind of
mechanism
of what we do if we're not just going to
get there by squaring every time what we
actually do is we do something called um
well in this case we're going to look at
something called left to right square
and multiply and the idea is we look at
the exponent 373 or eight or some other
number and we represent it in binary and
work out what operations we're going to
need to do
to get to the right
result i'm going to use a slightly
smaller example on this otherwise we're
going to have to bust out that pocket
calculator so we're going to do a 3 to
the power 45 mod 7. this is a strange
sum because in some ways 3 to the 45 is
an extremely large intermediate value so
we want to reduce mod 7 as much as
possible so that we keep it small
otherwise we get a huge value and we end
up at just a number between naught and
six anyway what a waste of time that was
but we can also use square and multiply
to make this much faster so first thing
we're going to do is work out what 45 is
in binary and that's 1 0 1
0
i'm going to draw a line here so we can
have some sort of delineation now a
couple of things to think about is
suppose we treat this exponent as binary
so what we want you want to do is
calculate
3 to the 101101
right whereas this is a decimal number
and this is a binary number so that's
slightly confusing i'm going to write a
little two in here to show us it's base
two
but a couple of things to think about
suppose you have
x to the one times by x to the one
that's in binary
all right so x squared
that's you're going to add these two
ones together so you're going to get
x to the one o
right
if you do
x to the one o times x to the one o
right so that's to the two times x to
two you're getting x and four it's
actually x to the one o o right so
whenever you square a number your
exponent shifts left one bit right it
doubles in size and shifts left you just
stick an o on the end of it a zero on
the end of it right if you multiply by
the original number so if you take for
example x to the 100
right it's not 100 it's one zero zero if
you take x to one zero zero and you
multiply it by the original x
that's actually just 101 so it's x to
the 101. right so you've got two rules
if you square a number
you take its exponent and you add a zero
if you
multiply the original number by your
intermediate result then you just add
one to the exponent right and so using
those two different square and
multiplies we can recreate
this exponent here in the minimum number
of steps so it might be three squares
and two multipliers exactly yeah and you
have to do them in the right order as
well right and so what we're going to do
is we're going to build up this exponent
here or this one here
by doing repeated square multipliers in
the correct order right so let's start
with three to the one right which is
three and what we want to do is now do
three to the 45 mod 7. now i'm not going
to calculate the actual values for a
minute we can fill them in a moment
right so the first thing we want to do
is we want to go from 1 to 1 0
right we're going from left to right in
this particular version of the algorithm
so to do that we need to square it so we
do
three to the one times by three to the
one
is
three to the one o
right so that's actually three squared
all right i'll tell you what i'll write
in three squared here so we can keep a
track of what the number is in decimal
so this is our binary this is our
decimal now we want to go from 1 0 to
101 we can't do that in one step we have
to do a square first so we do 3 to 1 o 3
to the 1 0 is 3 to the 100 right that's
three to the four so this is a square
this is a square and now we're going to
multiply and i've sort of not left
myself a huge amount of room here but we
won't worry about it so 3 to the 100
multiplied by 3 so the original value
that we have at the top
is 3 to the 101
that's 3 to the 5. all right now we know
we're near 3 to the 45 yet but hopefully
you can see we're sort of making some
progress let's keep going so the next
one we want to go from 3 to the 101 to
101 1 so we need to square again so
square so that's going to be 3 to the
101 multiplied by 3 to the 101
is 3 101 0. that's 3 to the 10 right and
if anyone's got their binary calculator
out you can confirm my working here
right let's keep going so we're going to
multiply so 3 to the 101 0 multiplied by
3
is equal to
three to the one oh one one so we've now
built up the first four bits of our
exponent we're not that far away i think
so that's three to the eleven and you
know 11's now we're near 45. you're
talking nonsense we're nearly there
right let's square that got us we've got
to square it right so 3
to the 101. one multiplied by i should
have just written squared
but then i would have had a lot of
little numbers floating about it would
have got a bit confusing 101 1 is 3 to
the 10110 which is 3 to the 22. we've
now got the first five bits of our
exponent and now we need one last bit so
that's going to be a multiply
um oh sorry no
yeah yeah yeah my bad square skip that
step we pretend that set didn't happen
this is why you use libraries to do this
like wall from alpha and you don't use
my implementation so that's three to the
one o one one o
times three to the one oh one one o is
three to the one oh one one o o which is
3 to the 44. now i think we're nearly
there right looks pretty good we're just
going to multiply one more time our
intermediate value of 3 101 100 times by
3 to the 1
which is one there and that's going to
be three to the one oh one one
oh one which is three to the 45. just
enough paper just enough paper
hopefully i don't need to add to this i
do actually i wanted to calculate the
actual sums right but you know now
so this is the this is the exact
combination we want if we're doing this
modular arithmetic then every time we do
one of these sums we can reduce it
modulo 7 and work out where it lands
from 0 to 6 and that keeps our value
very very small and we're also taking
the exact minimum number of steps uh so
it's okay to re-modular it yeah so so
when you're taking modulo all of these
numbers end up as equivalent and so if
you take mod all the time or you take it
once at the end or halfway through and
then once at the end it doesn't make any
difference it will just change the size
of the numbers so in general it will be
you do it as often as possible to keep
your numbers as small as possible when
you're multiplying numbers together
that scales very poorly with the size of
a number and so it's better to take to
make them as small as possible so let's
actually work through this so we can
just fill them in here so if i just sort
of created a little bit this is the
actual number we're going to calculate
here right so the first one is 3 to the
1 so that's
that's our starting number here you
could start at 1 and multiply by three
for your first bit you know just
unnecessary step right so the first
thing i'm going to do is three times
three which is nine mod seven is two
right so that's two
then this is going to be
three this is going to be the
intermediate value square so 2 times 2
is 4 mod 7 is also 4
right 4 times another 3
is 12 mod 7 is 5. right 5 times 5 is 25
but the next multiple of 7 below that is
21 so it's 4 is the answer right 4 mod 7
right this is not so interesting this
one so this is another 4 times 3. we
already did that it's 5. and when this
is 5 squared we already did that it's 4.
you don't usually cash your results like
i'm doing here i'm cheating really
finished so now 4 times 4 is 16
right the next multiple of 7 below that
is 14
right so it's 2 right
2 times 3
is 6 and that's the answer so if you do
3 to the power of 45 you get some sort
of quadrillion or some really large
number if you take it mod 7
6 right and we've saved quite a lot of
memory and quite a lot of time doing
this we haven't had to do 45
multiplications we haven't had to do
very large intermediate values this is
super useful for cryptography let's look
at 23 to the power of 373
mod 747. now i think they calculated the
answer actually was 131. i've run
through this just to see if it works and
it does i can say that for sure wolfram
alpha's code is correct on this but
let's look at this 373 in binary right
so that is 101
1 0 1 right which is quite long which is
probably why i'm not going to run
through it so we could actually i could
tell you what steps we need to do so
it's 23 to the 1 right that's gives us
our first one then we're going to square
then that will get us to here then we're
going to square and multiply and that
will get us the next one square and
multiply that's the next one square and
multiply
square
square and multiply
square
square and multiply
are you starting to work out why it's
called the square multiplier i think
it's something to do with squaring maybe
multiplication
so we could run through this so so if
you square 23 to the one you get 23 keep
going so multiply 23 to the 23
square that 23 283
now it's getting a bit hairy for me 186
23 to the 186
square again 23 to the 200 360 72 372
uh that actually makes sense that would
make sense
i could have worked backwards right if
only we could do that uh 23 to the 373
right so if you run through this on your
calculator and calculate models time you
will hopefully if you don't make a
mistake end up at 131. this is actually
quite a lot of steps let's see how many
steps we've got here so we've got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 steps and actually that
makes sense because for every zero here
we're going to need to do a square and
for every one we're going to need to do
a square followed by a multiply so it's
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13. so you
can see that even for sort of 2 000 bit
numbers exactly how many squares and
multipliers you're going to have to do
is going to depend somewhat on the
nature of this number and that leads us
to our my last part which is i wanted to
say that this is the best number that
there is right so this is 6 5 5 3 7.
right now i for a long time thought this
is the best number now i haven't been on
number file to explain why but there is
no doubt in my mind this number is used
as the public key which is a
verification key most time in in
the majority of rsa certificates right
so on the web when you go anywhere and a
server gives you a certificate the
public key will be this number here and
some large
um
semi-prime number n right now why is
this this well if i write out the binary
representation of this this is 2
to the 16 plus 1 which also happens to
be prime now the reason it's useful but
it's prime is because mathematically
then it doesn't share any divisors
with another number which perhaps we'll
go into in a different video but from my
point of view from this algorithm the
reason this is interesting is that is
the binary representation of that number
in rsa if you want to verify a signature
one of the things you'll do beyond
checking padding and a lot of other
stuff is you will calculate some message
or some hash of a message or some
representation of a message to the power
of 655.37
right and that's going to be slow except
it's not slow because there's hardly any
ones in here all right it's just you
start with one anyway you do a bunch of
squares and then you do one final
multiplication at the end and you can
verify very very quickly and that's
actually one of the reasons why rsa is
so popular right um
even though elliptic curve signature
schemes and other signature schemes
exist
it's hard to beat the sheer speed of
that verification process which is what
you have to do every time you go on a
website or anything like this so it's a
super useful function from a
verification point of view this is nice
and efficient now unfortunately private
keys tend to be much much bigger than
this
um because otherwise they wouldn't be
very secure because you could guess them
um so you are going to be doing
something like your message to the power
of or some message to the power of
a 2000 bit number right but on average
you're going to do what sort of 2000
bits so that's 2 000 squares and then
maybe half of them on average of ones so
it's maybe like one and a half the bit
length so maybe it's about 3 000 squares
or multiplies which on a modern computer
is not so bad it's not it's not trivial
right these are big big sums but it's
not ridiculous to imagine you could do
it consider it if you did it the naive
way where you did the message times by
the message times by the message two to
the two thousand times you would never
finish in the lifetime
of the universe kind of kind of deal so
um it's perhaps good that we have this
um the only other thing i should mention
by the way before uh someone corrects me
in the comments is
if you use this for a private key
the problem you've got then is that the
speed of your algorithm and indeed how
you know even things like the power of
your algorithm on the on the cpu
is dependent on what the private key is
right because you're going to be doing
different amounts of square and multiply
at different times depending on the key
and so you leave yourself quite
vulnerable to something like power
analysis where you can look at how much
power drain there is on the cpu and you
can see it go up for a square minute
from multiplying up to a square an upper
model and actually just read off the key
right and the other thing is that keys
with lots of zeros will be quicker to
use than keys with lots of ones in and
we don't really want to give away
whether your key has a lot of zeros or a
lot of ones and so actually there are
variants of this algorithm like the
square always multiply where you do some
sort of multiplication every time and
it's restructured in such a way as to be
constant time so that you don't have
that issue of if someone accidentally
has a key that has fewer ones than zeros
or something you know it changes how
long it takes
but because we can mod it by n each time
we're never going to have a number any
point that's bigger than 747 so each
time we multiply 23 by 23 by 23 by 23 we
just keep modding by uh 747 and when
that space what it's doing is it's
looking for extra areas where it can add
the nodes to build that graph up